you guys always asking about what I sing
every week and I've got the man who's
responsible for everything in that
regard this is Michael Graham you're the
director chopped music here the
University of Exeter and your organ
scholar at the Cathedral normal a clock
and they'd like oh you just got promoted
and yes it is so what is Chapel Choir
what do we do the chapel wire is formed
of 24 scholars and this gives us
opportunity to have essentially two
choirs
so it's a double choir we have 12
singers on deck Decca knee and 12
singers on contours the point of it the
point of having a chapel choir in any
coral establishment such as a cathedral
or a college chapel which is kind of
what we are really within the university
is really to lead the liturgy through
the singing of the magnificant and the
not de mythos and to include anthems and
to include music that would otherwise
cover movement so an array of very
simple things and that's just even some
really we also sing Eucharist which is
to sing that caught the mass setting and
the glory the Sanctus the benefit just
and the our newest and the key we're in
Advent school event obviously is a
religious purpose that we're singing but
not everyone in the chapel core is
necessarily Christian no not at all no
no II am the choral scholarship program
is basically a way of it's not just kind
of a bit it's a bit more than just we do
here in the chapel it's also an
educational program for you know
students that may come here and have had
singing experience or may not have had
singing in a church or liturgical
background experience but have done you
know kind of some singing I want to
carry on with it I want to sing music
kind of week-in week-out
improve their sight reading and then we
don't ask people to you know we don't we
don't just say like oh you Christian you
can sing here we ask people to be
sensitive to the to the to the liturgy
and to the worship that we're supporting
but yet Lee I'm leading in in our role
when most people think of Chapel choirs
I think I think it'd be fair to say that
a lot of assume we just do hymns yes
which we do we do look we got an example
here we'll have hot Hills yeah so this
is this is him that most people might
recognize and guide me with a great
Redeemer Simon's gonna sing it
you
so we do do we do do hymns every week
but what we had at the start was
something probably them the meat of what
we do every which is canticles yeah so
this particular version of the canticles
is an issue of what we sing in that it's
a single voice supported by other words
underneath yeah there are many different
settings of the non tomaters Magnificat
one we are looking at in this case is a
setting by our childhood it's Stanford
and it's his setting in G major the NOC
dimittis and the Magnificat start with a
solo which is quite nice in the sense
that it I suppose for the congregation
we can week out coming in hearing
different music it's nice to hear in a
different format as well and that's the
thing we do is a different set that we
do every week
absolutely yeah we're seeing different
music week in week out and obviously we
have to have different settings and you
know it's nice to be able to do so just
to compare we're now looking the
Magnificat which is the first part of
the canticles the same text can be done
in competing different ways
that was the setting by Stanford which
is for a solo voice and here is now an
example of the Stopford which is
different in texture which is chroma
phonic and the choir singing basically
the same thing altogether
so another thing that we do in the evens
on service every week is we do sounds
that's what we can do multiple songs and
they're different every week and this is
a different beast entirely yeah Sam
singing is is kind of the this this is
the kind of really challenging part of
of the core of scholarship people like
on what we do and some people have never
seen songs before a nice well so we
actually do them to Anglican
Chancellor's many different ways of
singing Psalms you can have Kagura
enchant which is kind of Northern
Ireland as that I serve and depart in
peace which is all to one melody or you
can have them in four-part harmony which
is how we sing them here in an Anglican
champ form which this is the this is the
chance on this particular
the choir will sing along to it this is
the soprano part and for this particular
song the waters are calming even on toys
wasting fast to muddy my one on DS I'm
coming to deep waters and there are 150
Psalms so there are many different
chance that we sing these particular
ones too and the other the other kind of
just going back to what we were talking
about before with the kind of 24 singers
and having antiphonal is that we like to
do ourselves in deccan camps so what I
just sound to you was two verses so the
first verse and then the second verse
starts with hiding fasting 31 so for
instance the first verse would be sung
by half of the choir and then the other
verse would be sung by the other half
the choir so deck and camp so we get
this kind of conversational tone so the
two sides they're literally facing each
other so it's like a conversation yeah
so yet another thing that we do and this
is this is really showing just like how
broad our task is every week we're
looking at set responses the responses
forms the opening and almost the closing
of the service really if you like that
this is the kind of response tree
between the what not what not
necessarily always a priest it can be
open or a comfortable from within the
choir but it basically introduces the
service so in in the Book of Common
Prayer you know the the rubrics of the
services at O Lord and our lips and the
congregation would respond and our
mouths shall show forth I praise the
priest says Oh God make speed to save us
and the congregation would say O Lord
make haste to help us and as we were
talking what we're saying before was the
role of the chapel that of a chapel
choir or acquiring and in any respect is
to lead the service so the congregation
role becomes our role respectively so
this is an example of one of the
responses we sing this is by William
Smith who was a 17th century composer
and this is more kind of more polyphonic
in the kind of responses we can do again
like the Magna knocks there are many
different setting the responses so the
priest would sing
Oh Lord opened our lips and we were
singing four-part harmony two systems
upon a part for instance go on Oh God
make speed to save us and so on forth by
that so moving then on to the other
service we do so we do eat us on every
week every every Wednesday at five
o'clock here and that's different is
Khepri week but we also do a Eucharist
every sight every other week which is a
mass setting is that month the vast bulk
of that the mass setting consists of the
kiri the Gloria the credo the sanctus
benedictus and the arms and that's all
in Latin this is all in this particular
setting is all in Latin you can get them
settings in English as well as many
composes them there's there are also
mass settings such as the limit Linux
the Berkeley Missa brevis which is has
been set in Latin and you can get it in
English as well so this is the mr.
Popham or celli which is a good example
of a prolific mass one of my personal
favorites by Palestrina and yours as
well I think and a lots going on in here
it's soprano alto split tenor and split
bass and when we say litany what we're
talking about is that each part isn't
moving what we call homophonic Li which
is kind of almost kind of like hymnody
really
I've been example homophonic texture
amplify each part really has its own
melody and has its own time to shine if
you like so the tennis kickoff soprano
is coming just afterwards and then the
bass is coming as well
so that was the only state from the mr.
Popham watch le this is a completely
different setting
what another difference master setting
that we do in our repertoire and this is
by Jonathan Duff who is a contemporary
composer
you still alive unusually for some of
the composing he's very alive what I
hope is so this is the Gloria from the
Dove Missa brevis completely different
texture and we have a much more
homophonic texture although it starts
with each part coming I'm kind of an
Tiffin Lee kind of answering each other
with them
Oh yo Gloria gloria in excelsis girl
Gloria so on and so forth and they all
come together and the urban part for
this is um quite fiendish in it yeah
that's good we're putting
so what's going on and the difference
between this in terms of you know it's a
much more modern piece lots going on not
just within the apply parts in the organ
part but actually in the timing of the
piece as well so even with the mass
setting with all the stuff from evensong
that still is nothing to do now because
we still do anthems and hotels we
Anthony's and motets all we also have
influences oh yeah yeah even movement
and one of the anthems we sing or indeed
as an inference as well is locust estate
which is a piece by the nineteenth
century composer Anton Bruckner which
means this place was made by God again
it's homophonic in texture so everyone's
kind of singing for all the same I think
the base of her partner's something been
there different oh that is true yeah
we're not having that in because you
just corrected me
and this is different to a little piece
of her - Liam that is unaccompanied so
yes if the masseter the Palestrina was
unaccompanied but this is noted it's a
very quiet very very different in time
we've done for example the done which is
chap quarters lowest yeah this is us
being very quiet and try and it I guess
a kind of the summit a lot what is what
is the Chapel Choir all about we our
primary function is to serve the chapel
which is to support the liturgical
services which is even some eucharist
and any other fifth day services that we
might be singing for alongside that
however we are also a fully functioning
concert choir we tour and take up any
opportunities really in and around devon
and indeed nationally as well which is
part which kind of forms part of our
outreach to go and to sing to other
people in other churches you know we
want to bring them in we want to show
them what x university has within its
you know it's musical talent in the
student body which is something that we
kind of very much valued at the
university wanted to continue to promote
them to you know to push forward and in
our core scholarship system in the way
that the Chapel Choir functions I hope
this was interesting too is to me if
you'd like to meet to do more on this
that I'm sure that we could arrange to
do some more stuff in the future yeah
definitely I mean well I quite like to
maybe do a video getting like a quartet
together from the choir maybe just doing
examples and few pieces nice if you get
up and so if you'd like that then do the
classic each of things like commenting
and liking and done hopefully we'll see
you back from here quite soon